[Music]
all right what's going on everybody's
Lorimar here from words of gaming dot
now I'm here with Shelly from Target
productions a PR manager of the studio
how you don't say she'll perfect very
well today we're going to talk about a
point click adventure called when the
past is around so talk a little bit
about the game so the game is a like you
said it's a point-and-click adventure
game so in this game you become a girl
named ada and she's trying to what is it
to unveil her memory about the Beast to
be all oh yeah so the full game will cut
this off 7 chapters ok perfect
so one of the things that really drew my
eye to this game is the art style now
what was the whole inspiration behind
that because as we know the Poynting
adventure the art style of a game can
definitely definitely a hater or not
cater but more to carry the entire story
itself so what's the what's going on
there so the the illustrator behind it
is a actually the game designer she is
Rena her name is Rena so her art style
is like a picture book ish and then it's
also
if you if you know her game her bus game
was named she and the Light Bearer
yeah it's also the arts is also like
that yes so she is really inspired by
nature so you can find many nature
elements in her game perfect it's it has
like a very serene and in the calm
nature to it and I'm sure that the
writing is just off the wall I mean it's
the because from if when I read the
description in the game it's going to be
a pretty heartbreaking but also
uplifting adventure for players actually
this when the passes around doesn't have
scripts so it's a silent game so you
yeah you you're you you you only have to
listen to the music and then just go
into that perfect well I'm a big fan of
music and video games
I love listening to soundtrack so okay
do I get a couple of a great songs
listen to on my way to work from Spotify
actually for this game we haven't have
any soundtrack out yet
what about the other game we have it
like she and the library which I
mentioned before
perfect we're well it's a beautiful game
what's the team most proud of when when
they when they when they started this
game or when they're in development it's
still in development actually you can
find the problem chapter for free in
steam yeah you can wait perfect okay so
when do you plan on releasing the game
this year hopefully on q3 cool cool
so what platforms are you looking to
target okay any plans for switch release
baby yeah Xbox one why not
but we are still focusing on steam first
perfect was looking like a fantastic
title good luck on development and all
the best to you guys on there anything
you want to sign off for for the game
now just find the product prologue
chapter on steam it's called when the
bus was around prague and then play it
for free be sure to check that out on
Steam this is Laura Montes signing off
floors of gaming net for all your news
game covers
[Music]
you
[Music]